oh right the microphone hi oh thank you
very much for having me it's a very nice
to be here so today I'm gonna be talking
about a paper with this rather long
title efficient structure and matrix
recovery and nearly linear time
algorithms for solving inverse symmetric
and matrices so this talk everything I'm
going to say is joint work work with two
students of mine at Stanford arun jumble
empathy and a Kieran sugar we tried
really hard this week it is so close the
paper is not quite on archive yet it'll
be online like Monday Tuesday if you'd
like a copy of the work or a draft
before then just email me after this
talk and I'll be happy to send it to you
in the next day all right so this talk
about is about this joint work with the
rune Quran and the problem that
motivates this talk and everything I'm
going to say in this talk is a rather
fundamental influential problem over the
last decade of solving a laplacian
system so the motivating problem for
this talk is we have some of the
plasticine matrix al we have some vector
P and we want to solve this linear
system l x equals B all right so just to
remind you what these are in case the
definitions aren't super fresh so L is a
laplacian matrix if it's a square matrix
that's symmetric it also has to be a Z
matrix with just as a fancy way of
saying every off diagonal entry needs to
be non positive it needs to obey this
tight diagonal dominance property
meaning that every diagonal entry is
exactly equal to the sum of the absolute
values of the entries and the
corresponding row or column another way
laplacian matrices are commonly
introduced so you can also define
laplacian matrices in terms of
undirected graphs so if you have some
undirected graph G with vertices V and
edges E and has some non-negative edge
weights W you can applying the laplacian
of that graph by simply taking the
diagonal matrix where every diagonal
entry is equal to the total weighted
degree of that vertex and used hit the
laplacian by taking that diagonal decree
matrix and subtracting it's weighted
adjacency matrix so you can see this
gives a natural by jek ssin between
these two objects what this says is
laplacian matrices we can think of as if
we have a little arbitrary laplacian
matrix we can make it by junction
between it an arbitrary undirected graph
simply by a sign looking at the entry IJ
and the laplacian for I not equal to J
and viewing that as minus the weight of
an edge from J and I to the graph now
solving laplacian systems is an
incredibly well studied problem over the
last decade or possibly probably longer
it's had numerous applications and I
think part of that has to do with a
number of different perspectives you
might take on solving laplacian z-- and
their applications alright so the way I
just motivated solving laplacian systems
is was is a rather natural linear
algebraic problem you can also show the
problem is equivalent to the problem of
setting up a network of resistors fixing
how much electric current enters or
leaves every junction over the resistor
network and trying to compute where the
electrical flow goes you can also view
the problem is more or less equivalent
to the problem of saying suppose we have
some undirected graph and suppose we
consider the natural random walk on this
undirected graph where we had some
vertex pick a random outgoing edge
random edge proportional to its weight
follow that edge and repeat then if we
want to solve something like we fixed
some vertex a and B and for every other
vertex we want to know that the
probability that the random walk gets
the vertex a before B that problem of
computing those escape probabilities for
all vertices is also essentially the
problem of solving laplacian systems so
I think one of the reasons for the white
influence of laplacian system solving
over the last decade has to do with
these different views of laplacian
systems and the fact that they sort of
naturally ode themselves to both sort of
continuous optimization perspectives
where we can view them as these linear
algebraic problems and try to solve them
by sort of natural can continuous
iterative methods like gradient descent
and coordinate descent and the fact that
we can also view them as these more
combinatorial problems involving graphs
resistor networks and random walks which
admit Lau's these problems to be viewed
by trying to solve them through
different sorts of combinatorial
decompositions of the graphs so owing in
part to these two perspectives there's
been a lot of work over the last decade
on how to use and improve methods from
each class and couple them together to
get faster and faster algorithms for
solving laplacian systems the first
results getting shown
do this in full was this beautiful
result of Spielman and tanning in 2004
that showed you could solve all these
problems in nearly linear time since
then there's been extensive work getting
faster and faster iterative methods and
new combinatorial decompositions and
work in this broad area of research you
may have heard of known as the laplacian
paradigm where laplacian system solvers
have been used it incrementally black
box - then get faster algorithms for a
whole host of combinatorial and
numerical problems so for a very large
list of rapidly growing list of problems
like Mac slow multi commodity flow
matrix scaling at some point in the last
decade in some parameter regime the
fastest algorithms we've had in some way
shape their form used our ability to
solve laplacian systems in nearly linear
time
and moreover beyond just these sort of
direct applications of using laplacian
system solvers black box there's been a
host of applications by taking these
iterative methods that have gone into
solving laplacian systems and using
those techniques for solving more and
more problems right so that's the
background for this talk the question
that really motivates what I'm going to
present and the rest of it is the
question of okay so we can solve
laplacian systems in nearly linear time
what other sort of structured linear
systems can we solve a nearly linear
time how far can we push the laplacian
paradigm from just solving laplacian
system to solving broader and broader
classes of linear systems and thereby
hopefully giving new iterative methods
and faster algorithms for more
applications right so even from the
original work and spilling tang and
earlier it's been known that there's a
broader classes of linear systems that
you might want to solve that really
easily reduce to the question of solving
laplacian systems for example there's a
rather standard reduction says if you
want to solve a symmetric diagonally
dominant system or an STD system so
these are systems in a symmetric matrix
where every diagonal entry is larger
than the sum of the absolute values and
the corresponding row or column there's
a pretty straightforward reduction you
sort of double the number of vertices
copy things the right way and you can
reduce that problem to solving laplacian
so there's also some really cool recent
work showing you can generalize this to
solving block diagonal dominant systems
where instead of having every diagonal
entry
some of the absolute values and the
corresponding grower column you get a
natural block analog of this you can
show you can still solve these in near
linear time whenever the block sizes are
small there's also this really cool
result I think of Dyson spiel in 2008
that showed you could do the following
suppose I have some matrix C that's some
M by n matrix where every row of C has
at most two nonzero entries okay now
suppose I look at the matrix C transpose
C alright so this matrix is the sum of
the outer products of a bunch of two
sparse vectors so this matrix is the
result of just adding a bunch of 2x2 PSD
matrices where you the rest of the
entries are set to be 0 yeah C is like
the edge vertex incidence matrix so
that's the proof that this is more
general than solving with Austin's so
yes and this says you can extend beyond
that but exactly right yeah in this
special case where C is something that
was the incidence matrix which I'll
define later which is essentially where
every row has exactly one positive entry
and one negative entry this problem is
exactly the same as the problem with
solving the Colossians however this is a
much more general and there was this
cool result of Dyson Spielman 2008 that
showed whenever you're given this matrix
C you can solve linear systems and C
transpose C these are known as factor
with two matrices so they showed that
you could solve factored factor with two
matrices in nearly linear time recently
we showed you can extend this a bit
further you can also be showed you can
also solve these systems in nearly
linear time even if you're not given the
factorization before hand takes a little
bit more work all right so can you go
beyond this what other linear systems
can we solve the nearly linear time one
sort of linear system you might notice
is conspicuously missing from the list
is all of these were symmetric matrices
right so nowhere have I said anything
about getting faster algorithms for
solving a symmetric matrices or there's
been a line of work over the last few
years showing that you can not extend
directly using laplacian system solvers
to solve these but you can extend the
machinery that's been used to solve
laplacian systems just get solvers for
asymmetric variants of these so you can
solve linear so I
line of work over the last few years we
showed you can solve basically directed
analogs of laplacian systems these are
outdegree matrices - adjacency matrices
they correspond to things like computing
stationary distributions and evaluating
policies so you can use the machinery to
solve these in nearly linear time and
just recently showed you could extend
this a bit further to solving a linear
system class of linear systems that are
a bit more general notice M matrices so
these are matrices where you have some
multiple of the identity minus some
non-negative matrix where that
non-negative matrix has spectral radius
at most s right you show up in a number
of applications and solving them
corresponds to things like trying to
compute perón vectors and solving
certain graph kernels all right so until
reason this was sort of the state of the
art there's been a very successful
paradigm or suite of techniques for
solving linear systems faster and it's
also beyond solving these systems it's
introduced a number of different
algorithmic frameworks for solving these
linear systems however if you go through
the sort of solvers that have been
developed over the last decade for
provably solving nearly linear systems
well has been a number of advances
coming from them and a very they're very
interesting and very powerful techniques
you can show that there are still some
ways in which laplacian system solving
is somewhat brittle there's so a number
of classes of linear systems we would
like to solve a near linear time that
are very closely related to solving
laplacian systems and yet we still don't
know how to solve them any better than
sort of the trivial runtime of ignoring
any of their structure and solving them
like an arbitrary system so let me
define a few of those all right so the
first is something I'm going to call the
perturb laplacian suppose we want to
solve the following problem suppose
we're given some symmetric matrix a and
we're promised that a is spectrally
close to some laplacian so when I say
spectrally close I mean that in terms of
the standard PSD matrix ordering of
looking at the quadratic form the
quadratic form for a is strictly less
than the quadratic form for L but it's
not too much less right so it's all
a largely quadratic form of L as long as
we scale it by gamma which you should
think of as some small constant or
something to be poly logarithmic alright
so this first problem is closely related
you can ask can we solve linear systems
and these matrices in nearly linear time
and you could also ask can we recover
the applause Ian so imagine be nice
we're given this matrix and not only
would be nice to solve it but sort of
write down the graph that roughly
corresponds to what this linear system
is so why would you want to solve this
problem one of the applications of
solving laplacian systems is when you'd
solve a number of when you do a bunch of
number of physical simulations you try
to approximate it by some linear system
and in turn laplacian systems are then
used as preconditioners for solving
these right so a standard paradigm for
solving some of these things is you
write down your approximation to get
some linear system you want to solve you
show that it's closely related to some
of the plasti and then you solve it it'd
be nice if we could sort of generically
prove you can always do that like
whenever you wrote down the matrix if it
was close to some of applause ian be
nice to prove you could provably get
that matrix and solve it it also just
seems like a fairly broad class of
systems that seem rather natural all
right so why first question you should
hopefully be asking is okay why can't we
extend our solvers to actually solving
these systems and the shortest
explanation I can give for why solving
these matrices are somewhat challenging
is suppose I have an arbitrary symmetric
matrix it has the all ones vector in the
kernel and every eigen value lies in
some bounded range right so think I just
have like some random entries and then I
just like project orthogonal to the all
ones vector that matrix is spectrally
well approximated by the laplacian of
the complete graph however seeing that
you have to do something to compute all
the eigenvalues and one of the nice
things about laplacian i defined
laplacian x' in terms of a natural
relation between the diagonal and the
off diagonal entries of the matrix so
you can just look at the matrix and tell
that it's a laplacian by looking at that
relationship however if I have a random
matrix right that's are talking about
the all ones vector right and you want
to check
that it's a little placing you can't
just do this sort of direct checking of
the entries you could have very very
large values and the eigen values could
be small because of signs of the off
diagonals canceling moreover if I take a
number of if I take that same
construction and do it on a subset of
the coordinates and do that for a number
of different subsets of the coordinates
and add them all up that'll also be a
perturb laplacian and now finding that
structure gets much more complicated and
it's unclear how to use than any of the
machinery to solve this particularly
given that most the machinery uses this
sort of entry wise analysis of the
matrix alright another class of linear
systems you might want to solve you can
imagine suppose I'm given a matrix a I
want to solve a linear system in it and
suppose this matrix a I'm promised is
the pseudo inverse of some laplacian so
it's the matrix that's the inverse what
the matrix you get by inverting all the
eigenvalues except for the zero
eigenvalue all right so suppose i'm
given this pseudo inverse of the
laplacian and i want to solve a linear
system in it or and then ideally also
recover the laplacian well why would you
want to do this you can show that being
given explicitly the pseudo inverse of
the laplacian is the same thing as being
given all pairs effective resistances in
a graph this is a natural pairwise
relationship between edges of a graph
you'd care about you can also show it's
basically the same as saying suppose for
an undirected graph I'm given a set for
every pair of vertices the weighted
commute time between those pair of your
vertices so the expected amount of time
it would take for a random walk to go
from one vertex to the other and back
again right so these are natural things
you might expect to measure about a
graph in different settings and starting
to recover L from the pseudo inverse is
essentially the same then as this
problem alright so again hopefully
you're asking all right that sounds
interesting but why can't we use our
previous machinery to solve this problem
there's two reasons one is one that I
guess I you know it hope to correct with
time we don't have a lot of tools for
just directly manipulating the pseudo
inverse
it's not immediately clear what
perturbations you can do to the
pseudo-inverse that preserve the
property of it being the pseudo-inverse
of the laplacian so it's not quite clear
how to manipulate them there's one other
argument I can give which is not a
direct hardness result it just sort of
shows sort of the difficulty in going
between a laplacian and its inverse you
might imagine since I've told you we can
solve laplacian systems in nearly linear
time you might imagine from that Laplace
things have such a nice structure I can
actually do better than matrix
multiplication and like writing down its
inverse all right so maybe I could hope
they'll be able to be right down the
inverse of a pseudo inverse of the
laplacian maybe use all the nice
structure that they have to not just
solve but go between the matrix and
inverse and back again so in some recent
work you can show that's not the class
you can show even if your laplacian is
fairly nice and well-conditioned the
problem of exactly writing down in
pseudo inverse is essentially is a sub
cubic boolean matrix multiplication hard
so if you wanted to do that you likely
have to use a lot of the algebraic
machine are using for used for fast
matrix multiplication so it says somehow
something else would be needed here
one more question you might ask so you
try to generalize this an even further
you could say suppose I want to solve a
linear system in symmetric matrix a and
I promise that a is the inverse of some
symmetric M matrix all right
so suppose you want to solve linear
systems in this what are these systems
so remember n matrices I define in the
beginning as these matrices that are
some multiple of the identity minus some
non-negative matrix where the special
radius is less than that multiple of
that identity you can show that such
symmetric M matrices are what they are
is they're just positive diagonal
scalings of symmetric diagonally
dominant matrices with non positive off
diagonals right and it turns out these
matrices actually do arise in a number
of contexts you can show that symmetric
M matrices sorry inverse symmetric M
matrices are the covariance matrices of
a commonly occurring class of
distributions known as MTP two
distributions that are used both they
both arise in a number of contexts and
they're used to a number of model of
probablistic processes so solving the
problem so solving inverse symmetric M
matrices is the same as solving certain
inference problems on when you have
these MTP to distributions and why is
this problem hard well it's not too hard
to show this problems essentially more
general than the problem with solving
laplacian c2 inverses so if you believe
me at all about laplacian pseudo and
verses being hard to solve this is only
harder all right so these are the main
questions that motivate what I'm going
to say in the rest of the talk and we
saw perturb laplacian selassie in pseudo
inverses or inverse M matrices faster
and I should point out that the
benchmark for these even though they
seem to have a lot of nice Kraft
structure be closely related to things
we can solve in a linear time before the
work I'm going to tell you about
essentially the best running time for
solving all of these systems and the
worst case ignored all the structure and
just solve them using fast matrix
multiplication all right so any idea how
to solve these systems
or any questions on the problem
all right so hopefully most of you are
thinking hard about how to solve these
systems some of you might also be asking
a rather natural obvious question about
the elephant in the room we you might be
asking wait a second
hopefully I've convinced you these are
interesting problems and they seem
worthwhile to solve but isn't this a
workshop on sublinear algorithms and
nearest neighbors search we're like
halfway through the talk nothing that
seems remotely rub out relevant to any
of these topics of stuff come up might
be asking him am I in the wrong room are
you in the wrong room what's going on
here why why are we talking about this
and so you might be naturally asking how
is any of this relevant to anything
about the workshop now the reason I'm
telling you about these problems and the
reason I'm presenting it here has to do
not so much with these problems
themselves but interestingly I very
interestingly I think the way in which
we actually show you can solve these
problems faster right so the main
results I'm going to tell you about or
roughly sketched out in the rest of this
talk is the following interesting
theorem that it turns out you can solve
all of these problems in quadratic time
so you can solve them an N squared so
you can solve them as if Omega was 2
even though it's not but interestingly
the way you can we show you can solve
welker we don't know if it's I guess not
too I guess
yes my keys interesting the way we show
you can solve all of these systems as we
show you can solvent and actually a very
very restricted Oracle model we show you
can solve these problems in N squared
where instead of having direct access to
the input instead of directly being able
to look at these matrices and do
algebraic manipulations of the entries
you can still solve these problems in n
square time if all you can do is do
matrix vector multiplies with the
matrices and you do only a poly
logarithmic number of matrix vector
multiplies so you can show for each of
these problems solving the laplacian
solving ax plus consider 2 inverse
solving a nearby laplacian you can solve
it where all you do in your algorithm is
apply the matrix to just poly
logarithmic number of that
so note this is trivially much less time
the number of queries than is needed to
actually fully and exactly recover the
matrices we're trying to solve and we
show so they run in sort of a sub linear
number of queries that would actually
need to recover the input and
interestingly we show that in these
results we don't just get these N
squared solving times but in the same
time we can actually write down a
special reproach summation to the matrix
so we can actually get a spectral
approximation to the laplacian or the
graph in each of these cases so in other
words this is a resort will prove this
theorem by giving a certain type of
matrix compressed sensing or matrix
recovery result showing that it's an ax
bumber of different settings it's
possible to really efficiently a proc
recover an approximation to a graph
using just a very small number of
queries yeah so I'm right soo
so laplacian if it's on the corrected
graph for full rank there and yeah we're
only gonna make a poly logarithmic
number of queries and we're still going
to get the full spectral approximation
we will be writing down rank n matrices
yeah so note that there's no
impossibilities every matrix vector
multiply is giving us n bits it's just
giving us n bits in a highly correlated
way right moreover I guess it's
important that we know for each of these
matrices there are sparse approximations
to them but actually we'll show that's
needed actually more for run time than
for existence of this result okay I'm
also just a few few notes about this
every time I write au tilde I'm hiding
poly logarithmic factors including the
log factors for solving the linear
systems and when I talk about solving an
N squared time for the problem of for
turbulence there's a polynomial
dependence on gamma I know that's kind
of necessary if there wasn't a
polynomial dependence on gamma I'd
basically be showing we can solve
arbitrary PSD systems and N squared time
which well then I'd be giving a
different talk and I probably wouldn't
then it might not be an appropriate talk
all right any questions on this result
before I discuss how we prove it your
claim clear
okay
all right so go for the rest of the talk
is I'm just going to really high-level
sketch these results of how I guess bad
pun not intended sketch these results
we're going to show you can solve all of
them by what I'm going to do is
ultimately reduce these to a sort of
general matrix recovery problem and I'm
going to show you can solve this very
general matrix recovery problem by
careful combination and slight extension
of a variety of very very powerful but
sort of known tools this combined with a
little bit of extra structure we'll need
to prove about laplacian x' in the
pseudo-inverse and perturbs laplacian x'
will then be enough to get the results
and I want to emphasize that I think
when we first phrased these problems was
very unclear how to solve it how to
actually get this sort of running time
the machine I'm going to use this very
powerful but sort of the approach I'm
going to take ends up being fairly
systematic and I'm presenting excite
think this general matrix recovery
theorem is a very powerful one that's
worth using in a number of other
contexts and I'm hoping this opens the
door to more work but I think the magic
of the result is more in that this
problems are at all solvable and that
this general matrix theorem is true once
I tell you how to solve it there's a lot
of technical analysis you have to do but
you hopefully would believe that the
ingredients work out questions so you
you gave these hardness results for
problem to that was exactly writing down
the pseudo-inverse
so good so if you have and also wasn't
we didn't we technically haven't shown
hardness the other way so the hardness
the heart the hardness is just if you
have a laplacian for if you have an
algorithm which arbitrarily given given
an arbitrary laplacian can write down
its pseudo inverse if you can do that in
sub cubic time you can do boolean matrix
multiplications of a cubic time so
there's nothing about approximation and
interestingly i would like to show this
it doesn't say anything about going from
the pseudo inverse dal which is the one
we actually care about for this problem
so it's only sort of it's not a direct
hardness argument is just showing why
it's non-trivial suggesting that it's
non-trivial good question though yeah
question
this house small gamma can be amazed to
make this still known for cool uh yeah I
guess any constant it's still any
conference even for any constant before
this we didn't know how to do it and
this does hold for any gamma so even if
gamma grows with n we can still show
this yeah so even if even if gamma is
like one over N to the hundred this is
we can do it it's just you know you get
some plus probably one over one hundred
so we didn't we didn't make any attempt
to actually optimize optimize the gamma
in the work is probably something less
than ten it's probably not less than one
I don't know what it is any other
questions
all right so goal is to prove this there
all right so how are we going to solve
these problems this is the these the
problems we want to solve I first just
want to point out right off the bat for
solving all of these we're gonna use a
very general linear system solving tool
probably the first tool you should look
at whenever you want to provably solve
linear systems the high precision and
that's preconditioning it's a very
powerful reduction for solving linear
systems we're gonna make heavy use of
and everything that I'm gonna say and
preconditioning just says the following
sort of simple fact suppose I want to
laughs solve a linear system in some
matrix a and I don't know how to solve
linear systems in a but I do know how to
solve linear systems in B all right
and if I run this very simple iterative
method which in every iteration applies
a to a vector and applies B inverse to a
vector this method very very quickly
converges to solving it to a solution of
the linear system and it converges at a
rate that just depends on how well a
multiply through the approximate B so if
they multiply clearly approximate each
other up to say some factor of gamma
then I'll take some gamma number of
iterations all right where every gamma
durations will get one more bit of
precision so I'll usually write such
running times as hotel bed gamma okay so
why is that relevant for this this says
actually for all of these problems the
hard part is not the hard part is not
actually in building the solver what
preconditioning says is the hard part is
actually just doing the recovery right
because what this says is say you want
to solve this problem and I gave you an
approximation of L well we said I said
we could solve linear systems in
laplacian in nearly linear time so you
can use it pseudo inverse as a
precondition air here and you would
solve linear systems in the original
matrix for the number of iterations
would just depend on gamma right so if
you can recover L you can solve right
similarly here this says if I can just
recover an approximation of L right that
it's is like the B inverse here I can
use that as a preconditioner and I could
solve and similarly here this says I
just need to recover approximation to
the M matrix itself and that would be a
good pre-conditioner so the hard part of
all these problems is actually doing the
recovery not doing the solving just one
quick picture for what this is actually
saying if you haven't thought a lot
about what it means to get matrix vector
access to a laplacian so what this me
one special case was a special case of
the theorem I'm going to kind of sketch
out it says is suppose we have this
large undirected graph then we play the
following game and every round of this
game we assign every vertex in the graph
some real value and what we can get back
is for every vertex we get the sum of
the difference of the value of that node
and the value of each of its neighbors
all right so we give everything of value
each node sums over all the edges that
difference and spits back the results
all right so now what the result is
saying is if we play so that operation
is just in English what it means to
apply L to the vector X and get the
output so what this theorem is saying is
if you play this game for a poly
logarithmic number of rounds that's
enough to spectrally approximate the
graph okay now when I say it that way a
natural thing that some of you might be
thinking about is you know some variants
of this problem have been discovered and
studied under the context of doing
matrix sketching we're trying to get
certain sketches of graphs to recover
properties of them can we use that
machinery so so I'm just this is like a
special case it's not all of them yeah
so this is mostly most analogous to
returnable Plus Ian's so the general
theorem you can apply in this is like
perturb laplacian when gamma is 1 which
is still non-trivial so this is a
special case of everything right because
if gamma is 1 I'm saying I've given up
lost in but I only have matrix vector
access to it right so even in that case
we know if I had the laplacian I could
solve it but if I only have matrix
vector how many do I need to recover the
graph and solve this is saying poly
logarithmic and that involves playing
this game ok all right
but the way I said it a natural tool you
might do might look to use this
different types of matrix sketching
right and there have been different
sorts of linear sketches from graphs you
could hope to apply all right so I think
that's the first idea you would take to
solve this problem to explain how that
works and why unfortunately we can't use
it
we need to introduce a little bit more
laplacian jargon that'll be very useful
for analysis
so some first some quick definitions for
any edge from I to J I'm gonna use Delta
e to denote this Delta I comma J and
this is just the difference of an
indicator vector for I and an indicator
for injector for J so this is just the
vector with a 1 coordinate I and a minus
1 in coordinate J now for any such edge
II I'm gonna let L sub e denote the
laplacian of that edge so the laplacian
of a graph where that edge is the only
thing in the graph and it's not too hard
to see that you know so we said that
Ossian of a graph you know had off
diagonal is equal to the weight and
diagonal equal is some of the off
diagonals so a plus seein of a single
edge is just going to be this matrix
that has 1 in the diagonal with entry
for i one of the diagonal entries for J
and minus 1 on the corresponding off
diagonals there and 0 everywhere else
can you think about it for a sec that's
the same is just the outer product of
Delta e and Delta e transpose so what
this means is we can write using this we
can write laplacian is a bit more
compactly so if I let B denote the
incidence matrix of the graph this is
simply the matrix where every row e of
this matrix is there should be a
transpose here the transpose of this I'm
going to call it like indicator of an
edge all right then we just argued we
can you can see that the definition of a
laplacian does linearize correctly so
the plus the other graph is just the sum
over all edges the weight of the edge
laplacian of the edge right which is the
sum over all edges the weight of the
edge Delta Delta u transpose and we've
defined B so this is the same as B
transpose W be sorry W is
diagonal good the diagonal matrix where
the diagonal entry is the weight so the
e teeth entry is the wood the way to be
so it gives us the right weighting of
the outer product so you're basically
the skimming goes into yes if we for one
we have a weighted graph yeah right so
if this was if this was a graph of an
edge of weight five this would just be
five minus five by five good question
all right so there's another nice way we
can write this one thing that's not the
nicest about this representation is this
definition of B does depend on the graph
it's not too hard to see if I let B sub
n denote the incidence matrix of the
complete graph I can also write L as B n
WM BN BN w BN transpose da un bien where
all I do is let WN be the matrix where
for every edge that was in the graph I
set the diagonal entry but the weight
and all these extra edges I add for the
complete graph I set to be zero so now
that we have all those definitions there
is a natural thing we could try to do to
solve this problem it has been shown
that given this representation there is
a way of taking a linear sketch of these
matrices to very efficiently sorry take
a sketch then a small number of
measurements does recover the graph and
this is a motivate this is the closest
annal analogous theorem to the one I'm
going to show I know if this was joint
work with a number of us a few years ago
said that if your weights are 0-1 so you
have an unweighted graph essentially
showed that there exists a distribution
over matrices with a just a yeah there
is this a distribution over matrices
such that if we apply that matrix to W n
BN we get a matrix that just is a log n
by n matrix so pi has just a log n
number of rows and it's the case that
from this sketch you can recover our
special approximation to the graph right
so the way to think about this result is
says we showed you can up if you have
the ability to apply just a poly
logarithmic number of matrix vector
multiplies to W
vn or the transpose of this that does
suffice to recover a spectral
approximation all right this is cool
this shows given certain representations
of the graph it is actually possible to
do this unfortunately I don't know how
to apply this result to our setting and
sort of the key issue is one of the
things this algorithm does or like the
analysis of this sketch does is it uses
that in this PI matrix when you're
working on this representation you can
randomly sample the rows of this matrix
which corresponds to randomly sampling
the entries of the matrix and you can do
this in a way where you're sampling
fairly independently between the rows of
the matrix
however if only all I have is matrix
vector access to L I don't know how to
get the same independence or do the same
sort of independent sampling so don't
quite know how do you apply this
machinery but going through this
analysis and thinking of what we're
trying to do or this fact that we can
always just write every one of our
laplacian ziz the sum of weights of
edges of graph it does suggest another
natural approach we could take at the
end of the day for things like perturb
laplacian x' right we are trying to find
this matrix l that's close to a and we
could just write down the optimization
problem that corresponds to and that's
just some semi definite program so if I
just scale things a little and shift it
this problem is the same as saying you
know I some want to find some weights on
every edge of the complete graph right
such that when I look at that weighted
complete graph what I get is a spectral
approximation to a right the recovery
problem just is this after scaling to
put gamma on the other side all right so
if we ignore for the second or actual
Oracle model and how we access the input
right solving this problem is just the
same as solving this semi definite
program right this assumption that a is
specially close to L means that there we
know that there exist some weights such
that this weighted complete graph is
actually close to the matrix a we want
to recover okay so what we could do is
just try to solve
this semi-definite program and somehow
we can solve this semi-definite program
in a way that runs in very few
iterations and makes very few queries to
the matrix a we could use this to prove
the result and for this fortunately most
of the work had already been done for us
all right so first so let me generalize
the problem I just said you could write
down this problem not just for laplacian
but an even more general form you could
say essentially what we want to solve is
the following we're given some
collection of PSD matrices so M
different PSD matrices and suppose we're
promised that there exists some
weighting non-negative weighting of
these PSD matrices that spectrally close
to some other given PSD matrix B all
right so in the case of laplacian is
this M is the set of edges of the graph
so this matrix recovery problem asks can
we find this vector alpha can we find
some rewriting of the mi that's pretty
close to B so maybe we only lose
constants over the best thing we could
hope for all right now it turns out when
I write writing this semi definite
program was mostly solved basically
implicitly in some very cool Berzerk of
yin Talley and Hassan they gave an
algorithm that actually solves this
problem in a poly logarithmic number of
iterations in the case when gamma is
very small like if sufficiently small
constant right it's a very powerful
result that you can solve this problem
fast at all it works by using packing
covering semi definite program suffers
and another iterative framework that's
kind of cool it's been this problem was
also written out explicitly in like the
laplacian case and solved and some other
other other reasons work our result
shows that what we're going to do is
show that we can the first step in
trying to solve our problem is to show
that we can if you look carefully at
these algorithms you can extend them a
bit to solve in the general gamma case
and if you look very carefully at what
the actual Oracle access the inputs
required it's something that we can hope
to generalize from right so taking this
perspective and generalizing this
results a little bit you can show the
following that there's an algorithm that
solves this problem and a poly one over
gamma
of iterations where in every iteration
the costs is the cost of doing the
following things of poly log or the
number of times you need to be able to
apply B and it's inverse to a vector you
also need to have some factorization of
B so you need to be able to compute C X
for some matrix C such that C C
transpose is B and also for any given
weightings of the mi you need to be able
to compute the result of some of I alpha
my product plied to a vector meaning
this matrix you have to be able to apply
to a vector and you need to be able to
compute the quadratic form of every mi
for some X so if you can do that in
every iteration you can solve the
problem at a poly logarithmic number of
steps so where does this come from
really high level these first two
operations are the way this is solved is
you do a change of basis to make the B
basically like the identity this is or
just what I wrote is a bit of overkill
for doing that operation and then these
steps are essentially what you need to
be once you've done this change of basis
to be able to compute gradients in
Dujail
all right and then feeding that through
this very powerful iterative method lets
you show this result okay so why is this
useful for us this first part seems a
bit daunting I say we're I'm saying we
want to solve this problem where we only
do matrix vector access to B and here
I'm requiring a lot more than that I'm
also requiring its inverse and the
factorization of it right however the
second part in the case of laplacian is
not too bad right these mi are just
going to be the indicators of edges
they're all too sparse there's only n
squared of them all of this we can do an
N squared right so to prove our results
right all we need to show is that
somehow we don't really need access to
all of this right that there's a way to
do something a bit more efficient so the
main framework results we use to get the
applications is we show that you can
still solve this problem in the same
time with the same oracles where you can
drop the need for being able to apply
this factorization and being able to
solve alright and what you need in order
to be able to drop these assumptions is
all you're essentially need
the same assumptions but on the matrix
you explicitly have right so if in every
iteration instead you can solve linear
systems and weighted combinations of the
mi where you know the weighted
combinations rather than being the B
that you don't know and you can get a
factorization of any weighted
combinations of the mi which you have
explicitly then you can get the same
result so you can get around the need of
being able to apply these operations to
this input matrix you don't have
explicitly you can do it just with
things you've already computed what's
nice about this is at least in the
laplacian case each of these operations
is N squared right so this result for
example immediately gives the perturb
laplacian result right so how do we
solve this this seems strong what I'm
saying is we want to be able to do
things like compute B inverse and apply
it's factorization to a vector and all
we have is access to B and we have the
same oracles for explicit alpha I am I
however there is an idea there's a
rather simple idea you can use to get
around this problem it's a natural set
of techniques that's shown up again and
again and solving different linear
systems and designing different
derivative methods I first know of it
from some cool result of Lee Miller and
pang in 2013 we've used it over and over
again for solving linear systems it's
just an easy idea known as basically
regularization and preconditioning which
you see ya just need to apply C to a
vector so if you want to boost it we end
up requiring the square run so you use
that you can get actual SP factorization
there's possibly ways to get around it
but but this works and getting around it
wouldn't save you anything for the
applications as far as I know okay good
question right so I'm running out of
time so I'll just say the idea very
simply very quickly the idea is to get
around this problem of not having use
Oracle's for beat all you do is you say
we'll take our matrix beam we'll add a
huge multiple yeah huge multiple the
identity and we'll suppose we can solve
or so we'll take our matrix B will add
some multiple the identity or I'll add
some multiple of the Mi these are
matrices we know explicit
and we'll try to solve the problem on
these matrices we can still do matrix
vector multiplies with this matrix
because we have this part explicitly
alright and the idea is just to show if
we the idea is just for very very large
values of lambda this problem becomes
easy because it's basically the
identities you can solve linear systems
and then you can compute square root so
you can do whatever you want but the
idea then is to say once I have solved
this problem for one value of lambda by
preconditioning I can use it to
implement the oracles for a slightly
smaller value of lambda so says if I
have matrix vector access so it says if
I've solved this problem for one value
of lambda right I can use the
factorizations I've computed for it and
the ability to solve it to solve linear
systems and compute factorizations for a
slightly smaller value of lambda through
an iterative method right so the idea is
to just run that framework I gave on the
previous I explained the previous slide
repeatedly decreased land and that gives
the result ok what's the high level and
actually doing this directly lets us
solve perturb laplacian alright so
that's all well and good but what about
pseudo inverses right how what do we do
there so the ideas will do the same
rough idea we'll take our a matrix a
that's the pseudo inverse of a laplacian
and add some big pseudo inverse to it
and try to argue that for very large
values of that we can still solve and do
everything we can use it to precondition
the next one basically if you can solve
if you can solve factor and in solve
factor and apply this for one then you
can solve factor and apply it for the
next and recurse down unfortunately when
I say this you should be a little bit
skeptical because of the following fact
is not necessarily the case that if I
have some non-negative combinations of
sum alpha mi and I look at its pseudo
inverse and I take some like
non-negative combinations of beta IMI
and look at pseudo inverse and then add
them and take their pseudo inverse
that's not necessarily still a
non-negative combination of the original
mi you know imagine these are just like
two different matrices right the pseudo
inverse of the sum of the suit
verse could be a very very different
looking matrix right so it's not clear
how to argue that like these pseudo
inverses even have like a nice
representation to work with so it's not
quite clear how to apply this to the
soon verse however there's a really nice
trick anyone know this it's like one
sentence
turns out we can prove this practice is
true for laplacian so it turns out if
you take the pseudo-inverse of laplacian
that a multiple of the pseudo inverse of
the complete graph and take its pseudo
inverse that's still a laplacian so you
can just work with that fun fun fact I
haven't seen it somewhere it's nice how
do you do inverse M matrices this seems
hard because there's this diagonal
scaling thing I haven't talked about
turns out there's a rather simple trick
you can use here turns out if you have
an inverse F matrix and you just apply
it to a vector and that will give you
some non-negative matrix such that if
you take its diagonal and you scale your
matrix by it then it's symmetric
diagonally dominant and if you're
symmetrically Dively dominant you're
non-negative combinations of two sparse
vectors you know explicitly and you can
run the framework you might be worried
about the same pseudo inverse inverter
issue but you can show it holds for sdd
matrices too that if a is an inverse of
a symmetric sdb matrix with non positive
off diagonals so is a plus lambda just
lets us run the framework right that's
all I want to say few quick open
problems I think the really big open
problem here is can we actually make
this run even faster so the actual
iteration cost of this the recover the
time to run every iteration is N squared
or in this general case we have
arbitrary PSD matrices ups I have to
apply every one of those matrices to a
vector which can be very expensive is
there way to do this faster it's very
closely related to the problem of trying
to do streaming special specifications
faster one of the things I really like
about this question is if you could do
it it would imply the following really
nice fact for laplacian so there's all
sorts of like implicitly represented
laplace things you might want to get
like tensors of graphs or random walk
laplacian z-- and if you could prove
this I would say the time that it takes
you to apply a laplacian to a vector is
essentially the time it takes you to
solve systems in it to regardless of how
complicated simplicity representation is
the difficulty in this is running the
framework you sort of have to do solids
of really complicated implicit laplacian
inside it that's roughly related to a
bunch of nearest neighbor problems that
we
myself right now other natural open
promises are actual this shows that in
theory these problems have enough
structure we can solve them faster you
know we're only solving them in
quadratic time they're not very
practical algorithms you know can we
actually better use the structure of
these problems to get something better
and I think one night other really
interesting question is note that this
algorithm is very adaptive right it is
making a number of adaptive queries -
well the laplacian to do the recovery is
that necessary so it's not necessary
when you have the incidence matrix once
you're in this framework do you need it
we don't know that's it Thanks so it's
time for a break very soon but maybe one
quick question anyone or we yeah
I'll talk to you about that offline good
good question it's on when you can what
you can do is you could a natural
approach to make this run faster is you
would open up the SDP solver and you
look at what you're doing in every
iteration and say what would uh you know
how what kind of access what I need or
what would I need to be able to do to
not actually explicitly have to keep
track of a wait for every single edge
and if you do that your weights are the
results of like a sequence of previous
linear system solves that go inside this
packing SME definite programming
algorithm and if you do that naively you
gets things where you know you have like
difference of two metrics and want to
get the larger of the two and it's it's
not clear some of them have if all of
them are some of them seem properly hard
it's not clear if there's one that's
just right
thank you so I think that's a break now